sono molto contento che questo
bellissimo formato di ted si è arrivato
anche a casa mia
ai castelli romani ed è un piacere poter
fare questa toti davanti a tanti amici e
tanti colleghi seduti in prima fila ma
anche nelle retrovie
io ho passato gli ultimi quasi dieci
anni della mia attività accademica
occupandomi di misurazione e allora voi
direte
mamma mia che che noia in realtà sono
molto convinto che misurando le cose in
maniera diversa noi possiamo cambiare il
mondo e possiamo cambiare il nostro
sistema economico
vi faccio un esempio noi abbiamo ormai
ci siamo ormai abituati a un modello di
sviluppo che è fondamentalmente
anacronistico ancora ragioniamo con
delle categorie concettuali del
novecento e purtroppo questo ci blocca
di fronte alla possibilità innovative
che ci presenta l'attualità e la
contemporaneità voi ricordate la cabina
telefonica l'ha ricordata da questo
concetto astruso e quella cosa quadrata
in cui una volta si entrava per fare le
telefonate oggi
fondamentalmente si usa o per i palazzi
dalla pioggia o per fare i bisogni
perché ogni tanto ci sono entrato anche
direttamente ed è un odore nauseabondo
quello che trovi in quella struttura
perché faccio riferimento alla cabina
telefonica
perché secondo il nostro modello di
sviluppo spendere per ottenere un
servizio fa aumentare il pil e quindi fa
crescere un'economia e quindi dimostra
che un paese più avanzato quando noi
facevamo le telefonate con la cabina
telefonica tutti spendevamo c'era un
gettone lo ricordate valeva per quelli
che ancora ricordano le linee valeva 200
lire oggi non la usiamo più perché oggi
ce l'abbiamo in tasca
abbiamo sistemi gratuiti con cui
comunichiamo dalla mattina alla sera
eppure paradossalmente quando noi
comunichiamo gratuitamente i nostri
sistemi di morazzini di misurazione ci
dicono che qualcosa non va perché non
pagando noi non stiamo contribuendo alla
crescita economica pensate per uno che
si occupa di misurazioni era meglio
quando c'erano le cabine telefoniche
una volta un turista che veniva frascati
la prima cosa che faceva era
andare in una tabaccheria una cartoleria
comprare una mappa delle strade per
ubicarsi spendeva dei soldi oggi non lo
fanno più
ma non è che non lo fanno più perché
siamo tornati indietro perché siamo
andati avanti con un modello
completamente diverso oggi ancora una
volta dei sistemi gratuiti che tutti voi
avete in tasca ti permettono di ubik
arti in tempo reale in tutto il mondo
pagando zero come con la cabina
telefonica il fatto che noi paghiamo 0
mette in difficoltà quelli come me che
si occupano di misurazioni perché crea
una dissonanza tra il modello economico
che noi cerchiamo di incoraggiare e la
realtà dell'innovazione che ci ha
completamente cambiato il sistema
economico intorno a noi
e il paradosso lo sapete qual è e quando
tutto questo accade i governi cominciano
entrare in fibrillazione e anche le
autorità economiche cominciano a dire
attenzione attenzione qualcosa non va la
tua economia è in difficoltà
questo non accade soltanto in paesi come
l'italia ma accade accadeva già dieci
anni fa in america nella stele canale e
tutte queste cose vengono profondo
fondamentalmente da lì è cominciato un
paradosso
il paradosso della produttività lo
chiamano gli economisti cioè
improvvisamente qualcuno ha detto occhio
che con questa informatizzazione e
innovazione dell'economia
rischiamo di non poter crescere più come
prima
e son cominciate tutte le tesi anche
piuttosto stravaganti per cercare di
mettere il bavaglio all'innovazione per
cercare di contenerla per la paura che
l'innovazione facesse male all'economia
voi vedete questo paradosso è così
evidente invece di capire che l'economia
stava cambiando che l'economia non è più
quella di una volta in cui spendiamo per
ottenere tutto ma che sempre di più
concepiamo tante attività gratuite come
aventi un valore importante addirittura
un valore di guida del progresso
ecco noi abbiamo ancora delle
strumentazioni che non ci permettono di
cogliere questa finezza io sono stato
varie volte negli anni in un paese che
si chiama costa rica a un paese forse in
cui molti di voi non hanno mai viaggiato
ed è un paese che è questo vive questo
paradosso considerate che il paese che
ha la più alta aspettativa di vita di
tutto il continente americano grande di
gran lunga più lunga di quella degli
americani è un paese in cui l'educazione
la scuola e gratuita per tutti così come
la salute
cosa che in america non esiste eppure in
base ai nostri parametri economici è un
paese sottosviluppato mentre il suo
fratello maggiore
gli stati uniti d'america dove
l'aspettativa di vita è più bassa dove
bisogna pagare per ottenere un una
prestazione un servizio sanitario che
molto spesso è inferiore anche in
qualità ma costa molto
per la stessa ragione è considerato un
paese sviluppato
noi continuiamo ad operare in questo
sistema economico come se avessimo le
categorie del novecento perché nel
novecento funzionava così l'idea
qual'era l'economia migliora e abbiamo
sempre più cose da comprare che
costeranno sempre di più quindi il
sistema funzionava
poi alla fine del novecento con questa
rivoluzione
molto spesso molti casi dovuta internet
ma l'evoluzione innovativa in generale
si è creato un paradosso
cominciamo a fornire ea utilizzare beni
e servizi che costano sempre di meno o
addirittura non possono più nulla
si è creata quelli che molti chiamano
l'economia della gratuità un paio di
anni fa nel 2016 specificatamente in
inghilterra il direttore generale della
banca d'inghilterra venne commissionato
dall'allora primo ministro david cameron
una ricerca come misurare il valore di
ciò che è gratuito come fare in modo che
le che il politico il governo non
commetta l'errore di pensare che quando
si crea un economia della gratuità
stiamo facendo un passo indietro ma
invece sottolineare il fatto che sta
facendo un passo in avanti e lui fece
una serie di analisi e fondamentalmente
concluse che se non cambiamo il nostro
sistema di misurazione non ce la faremo
mai è come se avessimo un termometro che
non mi sono più la febbre
qualcos'altro e noi continuiamo a
sbagliare a non comprendere la grande
capacità innovativa ea creare una nuova
economia lo sapete cos'è questa economia
nuova le corriere del passato alla
economia delle cose lo sviluppo era il
ponte allo sviluppo ed al palazzo un
politico che voleva essere ricordato
doveva costruire qualcosa di cemento
oggi l'economia non è più quello è
sempre meno quello il grande valore che
non riusciamo a misurare e questo quello
che abbiamo qui dentro perché le app che
voi portate nelle vostre tasche
nascono da qualcuno che avuto un'idea
perché tutti gli strumenti che oggi ci
permettono di creare questo valore che
non riusciamo a misurare nascono
dall'intelligenza e dalla conoscenza
delle persone
quindi io direi l'economia si sta
modificando passando da un'economia
delle cose un'autonomia delle
infrastrutture che si possono toccare a
un'economia sempre più materiale
un'economia della conoscenza la potremmo
chiamare ecco noi dobbiamo favorire
l'economia della conoscenza anche con
strumentazioni giuste con sistemi di
misurazione giuste altrimenti saremo
sempre in contraddizione rispetto alle
politiche
cioè l'economia vuole andare in una
direzione di materialità sfruttando la
conoscenza eppure le politiche la
spingono a tornare verso il novecento
verso gli strumenti del passato
per questo molto spesso voi sentite dire
dalla politica che l'educazione ha un
costo un posto importante
nessuno lo nega ma un costo il termine
costo è sbagliato l'educazione
l'istruzione è un investimento tra
l'altro quando utilizzi gli strumenti
che abbiamo costituito noi ti accorgi
che è un investimento da paura è il
miglior investimento che ti può capitare
investire nella conoscenza ha un ritorno
economico di gran lunga superiore
rispetto ai ponti alle strade che non
serve neanche la manutenzione non serve
gli altri a tappare le buche
ecco l'economia della conoscenza è
l'economia del futuro ed è anche
un'economia sempre più verde sempre più
sostenibile è una economia che ci
permette di immaginare nuovi modi di
fare le cose
e chissenefrega se queste cose non
produrranno
degli effetti monetari immediati sulle
infrastrutture perché quello che importa
è creare valore aggiunto e benessere e
perché dico questo
in un contesto come quello in cui ci
troviamo
perché paradossalmente questo luogo dove
sono nato e cresciuto è forse il posto
in italia che più ricorda l'idea di
questa economia della conoscenza ed al
tempo stesso vive questo dissidio noi
siamo qui a frascati nei castelli romani
dove c'è la più alta densità di centri
di ricerca nazionali e internazionali
dell'intero paese
siamo in un posto dove ogni 3 400 metri
ti imbatti uno scienziato magari che si
è perso perché non ha trovato la cartina
stradale è un posto dove nonostante le
difficoltà territoriali
c'è la più alta densità storica di premi
nobel di tutto il nostro paese c'è la
via enrico fermi non me ne voglia il
sindaco questa una battuta che faccio
perché so che è stata rimessa in ottime
condizioni ma fino a qualche tempo fa
passavi da una buca un'altra per andare
a conoscere i grandi scienziati di
questo paese da un acceleratore di
particelle ad un grande percorso di
sperimentazione magari sulla fusione
nucleare nel giro di poche centinaia di
metri dall agenzia spaziale italiana
all'agenzia spaziale europea livelli di
altissima conoscenza
eppure una delle zone di della provincia
con la minore densità di laureati con la
più alto livello di dispersione
scolastica con livelli di degrado non in
questa zona dei castelli romani ma basta
scendere andare nel quartiere dove io
sono cresciuto tor bella monaca per
trovare sacche di criminalità di degrado
profondo problemi sociali cioè questo
queste due economie che non riescono a
dialogare tra di loro
ecco da qui la grande è la grande
scommessa la grande scommessa è possiamo
metterci al passo con il resto del mondo
con le economie più avanzate che hanno
capito che l'economia
della conoscenza è l'unica economia che
può permettere alle società avanzate di
continuare a crescere perché tu non puoi
continuare a costruire ponti e strade su
ponti e strade all'infinito ma l'unica
cosa su cui poi continuare a investire è
quello che abbiamo qui dentro
e magari trasformare questa zona questa
parte di roma che già 50 anni fa i
grandi scienziati del nostro paese
avevano individuato come la culla della
conoscenza
ecco trasformarla in un grande esempio
di una nuova economia una economia della
conoscenza una economia del benessere
un'economia della sostenibilità dove a
partire dalla scienza a partire dalla
ricerca si investe nelle persone si
investe nelle aziende innovative si
avverte nelle startup si investe nelle
scuole si investe sulle cose belle che
fanno questo territorio così unico a
partire dall enogastronomia alla cultura
al fatto che abbiamo non soltanto così
tante realtà scientifiche ma che siedono
al lato di grandi reperti archeologici
che abbiamo quasi dimenticato
nell'illusione che soltanto il nuovo a
valore che è soltanto quello che brilla
e luccica valori io venendo qua non
potevo fare a meno di ricordare come le
mura romane costruite migliaia e
migliaia di anni fa sono ancora lì e
funzionano hanno grande valore i nostri
edifici dopo 34 anni cominciano a
crollare a pezzi e allora c'è qualche
errore c'è qualche problema in questa
economia del consumo costante che non ci
permette di vedere il valore lì dove si
genera è l'unico valore che oggi davvero
riesce a generare le grandi innovazioni
così come il superamento della cabina
telefonica
così come il superamento della cartina
stradale fatta di carta che compie al
tabaccaio noi oggi ci troviamo di fronte
la possibilità di un nuovo modello
economico e poterlo sperimentare proprio
qui in questo territorio a tanti di noi
così caro che può diventare un fiore
all'occhiello una un esperimento
pionieristico per il resto del paese
dimostrare che investendo non spendendo
investendo in ricerca e formazione si
creano le condizioni per il momento la
fase migliore di crescita e di progresso
di un territorio di questo territorio in
questa parte di roma
si consuma un esperimento si potrebbe
consumare un esperimento di qui a
qualche anno che potrebbe essere
capofila per un dibattito internazionale
sono sempre di più i paesi che
riconoscono i problemi con l'attuale
modello di sviluppo sono sempre di più i
paesi che si rendono conto che non si
può continuare così e sono sempre di più
i paesi che puntano a sostenere
l'economia e immateriali il costa rica
oggi è il quarto paese al mondo dal
punto di vista di attrattività delle
start up e le aziende innovative
queste in genere sono aziende che
inquinano di meno investono sulle
persone e investono su cose che
migliorano la qualità della vita anche
sul sull'ottimizzazione dei consumi la
scozia un altro paese in cui ho lavorato
continua e spinge per un'economia sempre
più spinta verso la conoscenza non ho ma
se landa che voi forse conoscete meglio
ha puntato già da alcuni anni su
un'economia che punta proprio sulla
formazione che sottolinea l'importanza
della formazione perché vogliono essere
l'economia più competitiva dal punto di
vista della conoscenza non si
preoccupano di altro dal punto di vista
della conoscenza
entro il 2030 al mondo ecco questo è il
modello che noi dobbiamo abbracciare e
lo dice lo dice la metafora stessa
noi non vogliamo più la cabina
telefonica alla cabina telefonica come
londinesi fate una foto trasformarla in
un souvenir e per i turisti ma il futuro
non è più la cartina del giorno la
cartina di carta la cabina telefonica o
quello che sembrava essere il progresso
del novecento
il futuro lo portiamo tutti in testa ed
è quello di cui abbiamo bisogno ed è lì
che dobbiamo investire
grazie grazie grazie mille lorenzo
grazie